[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER KOHLER: We're here
to talk about how we're
revealing an ocean under siege.
And as Florian said, how we're
sort of using technologies
in science and machine
learning and combining
that in a really innovative and
sort of cutting edge way to try
and reveal just how much
this ocean is under siege.
But first, I want to start
where it started for me.
So I was fortunate enough
to go to the South Pacific,
find a skipper who
needed some crew,
and jump on board
for four months.
And I spent four months sailing
around what you can only
describe as a paradise.
I mean, it really was the
picture postcard ideal of it.
But it was a
paradise under siege,
and we could see
that everywhere.
And perhaps the
most, you know, I
don't know if this
video is going to work.
So you have this off the
bow of the boat, dolphins
jumping around.
It is pure,
beautiful blue as you
are [? sees ?] and
the next thing which
you can't help but
not see, I mean
this is actually in the UK.
But-- if it loads,
will it load--
is quite literally a plastic
tide, a tide of litter
washing up on the beach.
And you can see this
from this drone footage.
You can see all the litter
items just washed up.
And this was everywhere.
So every tropical remote
island you went to--
and I'm sure you've all heard
it in the news, but you know,
this was back in 2008.
So when I came back, it really
was something that bothered me.
I wanted to know how much this
is affecting us and the world.
And so I started
looking into it,
and I started finding ways
in which I can do something
about it.
And very quickly,
I found that it was
a massively growing problem.
So this is-- it costs around,
the world economy, around $8
billion a year at least.
You'll see a World Bank estimate
that's closer to $12 billion.
It's an exponential increase
in global plastic production.
So by 2050, we're looking
at 1.8 billion tons a year.
And then I'm sure you probably
heard some of these quotes.
This is from
MacArthur Foundation.
By 2050, there could be as much
plastic in the ocean as fish,
20% of our oil
production will be
devoted to plastic
production, and something
like 15% of the global
carbon footprint
be because of plastics.
So they're quite harrowing
figures, but what
sort of impact does that have?
This is the actual
impact, and apology.
I probably should have warned
you guys ahead of that.
But we've got plastics inside
fishes' digestive tracts.
So this is out in the Pacific.
I think this is an albatross.
Seals entangled and
whales entangled.
So that's the reality.
But it also impacts
us through something
called bio-accumulation.
And not a lot is known about
the toxicity for humans.
The biggest concern is
that with micro-plastics,
as the plastics break down,
they turn into micro-plastics.
Those micro-plastics
act as magnets
to attract pollutants--
persistent organic pollutants
in the water.
And there's a lot of
interest as to what happens.
Do they move from the digestive
tract into the fish's flesh?
And then if we eat that, then
do we take on some of that
ourselves?
Does it accumulate up
through the food chains?
So there's a lot of concern
around that at the moment,
as well, and there's
a lot of research.
It's a research priority.
Just some other key facts,
which I'll just throw up there.
There's a particularly
telling one.
8.3 billion metric
tons of plastic
have been made since forever.
79% of that has gone to
landfills or the environment.
By the way, I apologize.
My voice is quite squeaky.
If I sound like a
teenager, I'm sorry.
It [INAUDIBLE] it should last.
So yeah, those are just
some facts and figures
up there for you.
And so it is a complex problem.
There's no silver
bullet to it, right?
You'll hear lots of
things, like oh, we've
solved it by having
worms that eat plastic.
I think the most recent
one was an enzyme that
dissolves plastic.
But that's just the
end result. There's
still a systemic
failure in a way
that plastic is
leaking and used for--
for example, single
use, plastics as you
would have heard.
So when I was tackling this
problem, I was thinking, well,
where does it start?
Where do I even start?
It's a huge issue with
many facets to it.
But then one fact
struck me the most,
and this is actually from
one of-- a paper by one
of our science advisors--
Dr. Erik van Sebille.
99% of the plastic is missing.
Once it enters the ocean,
we know about where 1% is,
and that's on the surface.
It's basically unaccounted for.
We don't know the precise
mechanisms of where it goes.
It's believed that
this may just sink
to the ocean floor, coastlines,
the upper ocean or the surface,
or in the biota submarine life.
So we sort of want to build a
3D picture of how this is setup.
And that is important
because it helps us resolve
the impacts that plastics make.
So this is a quote
from a paper in 2014.
Knowing where it goes, where it
ends up, where it concentrates
is key for us to understanding
what the impacts are.
How does it impact human life?
How does it impact marine life?
How does it impact plankton?
And a lot more papers
struggle to identify--
so the problem is that
there's not enough good data
to sort of quantify those
concentrations in those sinks.
And especially in
regards to coastlines.
So because of our inability
to collect data accurately--
there are estimates there where
we could be underestimating
the amount of plastic by
an order of magnitude,
potentially, on beaches.
So the problem could be far
worse than we think it is.
And this really struck home to
me, having been on the beaches
in the South Pacific and
having seen it firsthand.
This missing element to it
really tweaked my curiosity
because at the time,
I just wondered
where it could all come from.
I mean, you'd find things like
flip flops and toothbrushes
and all sorts of
things on beaches--
even the bow of a ship, which
had washed up somewhere.
So it's really
incredible what you find.
So that led me to found the
Plastic Tide, where we're
trying to identify where those
plastics come from-- where they
accumulate, where do they go?
What are the fluxes?
So our vision is striving
for a plastic-free ocean
for humanity.
So by understanding
where that plastic is,
it can lead to our mission.
So it's to reveal how
our ocean is under siege
and to use that knowledge
to better inform
cleanup operations, to better
inform the damage limitation--
impact limitation.
And we'll go on to a bit
more about that later
and the preventative efforts.
And so who are we?
As we can see, so
this is our team.
We've got a team of trustees.
Ellie and Dirk are here with us.
No, sorry.
Ellie's here with us.
Stefan, of course, and Dr.
Arturo Castillo is here.
But we've also got Dr.
Kayleigh Wyles, who's
been doing some research
with us on the environmental
psychological
impacts of beaches,
as well as Erik, who's really
interested in those ocean
circulation aspects.
So how are we doing this?
How do we detect the plastics?
How do we find out where
that 99% is missing?
Essentially, it's
turning what this
is-- so this is Janie, who
was out with me and Ellie
on Calgary beach on the
Isle of Mull, manually
cataloging plastics
that I collected.
Very time consuming.
Takes a lot of time.
No one wants to do it who's
cleaning beaches because they
just want to clean the beach.
They don't want to
have to sit there
for hours figuring how it is.
And as a result, we found--
Ellie and I found that
people in Cornwall
would classify what we thought
was the same plastic completely
differently to someone
up in Scotland, even
though these people
are both professionals
and they both know
what they're doing.
So there's a real problem in
getting that clear picture
of the concentrations
of plastic, which
will help us understand the
fluxes and the dynamics,
which can then inform
campaigns and inform policies
and that sort of stuff.
Again, we'll talk about
more of that in a second.
So we set out--
and yes, so replacing
that with drone surveys.
And so we set out to create
a vision from the skies,
basically, where,
as you can see here,
Ellie is collecting
and surveying beaches--
Rhossili in Wales-- for
plastics and litter.
That gets uploaded to a platform
called Zooniverse, which
is, as I said, in
Science Universe, which
you can log onto right now.
And you tag any plastics
that you see in that image.
I just uploaded a fresh
batch from some US beaches
last night.
So it's nice and
steaming hot for you.
And then we apply machine
learning, which Stefan
will talk about in a bit.
And then from that, we
can identify plastics.
And this is the results
from our sort of prototype.
But eventually, we
want to sort of cut out
the machine learning
and the training bit,
and go straight to the automatic
and autonomous identification.
And that's the sort
of end goal, is
to have this algorithm
that we can then
deploy using drone platforms
and scale up that monitoring
and detection effort.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, how did you
say this platform is called?
PETER KOHLER: This one?
AUDIENCE: Zooniverse?
PETER KOHLER: Yeah,
this is Zooniverse.
Yeah.
I'll send some links.
There's some links
at the end, and I'll
send some to Florian, as well.
So these are the 33
beaches around the UK
that we collected data from.
Some of them were
our prototype beaches
and others were the main ones.
So you can see--
so we go to the
beach, scan them,
and then we did a
clean afterwards.
Every scan we do, we
follow with a clean.
That journey led to us finding
some of the strange things.
So the child wasn't the strange
thing to find on the beach,
by the way.
The little Lego cutlass,
which he found here,
was-- and that has a story.
So that was a very rare
piece item, which--
something like 5
million, ironically
enough, marine themed Lego
pieces fell into the Atlantic
just off the coast of
Cornwall 20 years ago,
and they're still showing up all
over the southwest of England
and as far as the Gulf of
Mexico and even Melbourne,
in Australia.
So if you do go to
the beach holiday,
keep a lookout for these
because they are collectible.
We gave it to Josh
here because Ellie
and I wanted him to be a sort
of future ocean guardian.
And we're happy to
say that Josh is
extremely enthusiastic
about cleaning beaches.
So one day, he might be coming
here and doing a presentation
to you guys, hopefully.
But we also found a
solar powered mushroom.
Not quite sure why.
And we found a toilet
seat, which was great.
But we also found
the bad and the ugly.
So this is a Russian
mouthwash from Lever Brothers.
A bit of brand naming there.
Apologies.
We found that in Norfolk.
Phosphoric acid containers--
four of them on the beach,
just sitting there.
And a medical
catheter in Scotland.
And that's just a sample.
And then a syringe
on the far right.
And that's just a sample
of what you'd find.
That leads to this.
So this is an example
of a scanned image.
This is cut up and
Stefan will probably
talk about it in a second.
This is cut up
into smaller tiles
and then uploaded
on to Zooniverse,
where you can then tag it.
This is an example of tagging.
So you draw a little box, select
which from the dropdown list,
press OK, and
that's one tag done.
And without further ado,
I hand it over to Stefan
now, who's our science advisor
and lecturer in robotics
and computer vision.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
STEFAN LEUTENEGGER: Thank
you very much, Pete.
OK.
So I decided to give a bit of
a general perspective first
on what we're actually
doing at Imperial College,
and how this all feeds
into efforts, in relation
to the Plastic Tide.
So my interest, and
that is collaborating
with a lot of researchers,
especially professor Andrew
Davison at Imperial College,
is to work with mobile robots.
A lot of things can be
classified as mobile robots.
We work on the
kind of technology
behind mobile robots
that can be applied
to all kinds of scenarios.
Talking about
domestic robotics, we
have some funding from
Dyson, the vacuum cleaner
company, for instance Drones
is a big interest of mine,
but obviously, also,
in autonomous driving--
in principle, this is
an autonomous robot
that needs very much similar
technologies for autonomous
operation.
We're also very interested
in advanced manipulation,
and things like
environmental monitoring
is one of these
applications, as well.
So if you want to deploy a robot
in a fully autonomous way, then
kind of traditionally, you have
to solve a couple of problems.
And a typical real
time control loop
that would be running on a
robot looks a bit like that.
You have a kind of
perception module here
that senses the outer
world, and then you
interpret all of this data--
maybe also some internal fencing
to try and answer questions
like, where am I?
What does the world
around me look like?
And with this basis,
you can feed that
into some kind of higher
level intelligence, cognition,
planning of actual motion, kind
of addressing the questions
about what should the robot do
and where should the robot go?
And then finally, you'll have
to come up with actual signals
that you sent to the motors
to make the robot move
and to actually achieve
what was planned,
such that it will
then change its state
and the whole thing
repeats, right?
And so this can be really quite
difficult to do because we
have to do it in real time.
This can potentially run
something like 20, 30 times
a second.
We have to process the data
and everything on board.
We wouldn't want to rely--
for these critical things,
you wouldn't want to rely on
sending something to a server
and waiting for a response.
And that my fail.
So we have to have
efficient algorithms.
They have to be also robust.
They have to be also
accurate enough, such that we
can achieve a certain task.
And I would say the kind
of specialty of our labs
is somewhat on this
side of things.
Where the whole thing begins--
the cycle begin-- its all
around simultaneously localizing
a robot and understanding
mapping the world.
So this is a bit of a chicken
and egg problem, and just a bit
of a summary of how we usually
tackle that is given here.
So there's one piece of
research, which is all about--
it's mostly centered
around accurately
determining position
and orientation
of the mobile robot.
OK.
So you use several sensors.
We definitely rely heavily
on computer vision here,
but we might combine it with
inertial sensing, for instance.
We build kind of a sparse map
of just a couple of landmarks
in the 3D scene, and
at the same time,
try to find out where the
robot here represented
with this kind of
coordinate frame--
where it is located in
a kind of global frame.
Of course you might have GPS.
You might have
certain aides that
help a lot in this problem.
But in a general case-- for
instance in the robotics,
you wouldn't have that.
In the context of the Plastic
Tide, we do leverage GPS.
Of course I would
always argue when
you have these kind of things
available, then you should.
So that's kind of
the first level.
You can already do
quite a few things,
but when it comes to, for
instance, avoiding terrain, not
crashing into something,
doing safe kind of autonomous
navigation in
unknown environments,
then you need some form of
a [INAUDIBLE] kind of a map.
You need a geometric
understanding of the world.
So this is the kind of next
level that we are addressing.
I will be just showing a
little bit of examples here.
And then I think
that the third level,
with enabling somewhat
higher level understanding,
is a semantic one.
You don't want to only
understand where stuff is.
You want to understand
what stuff is.
And that very much now ties
in with the Plastic Tide.
We want to have a mapping
system that identifies
the semantics behind things.
This is an indoor example, but
it employs very much similar
techniques as what
I'll be showing
applied to the Plastic Tide.
So we leverage
deep learning here
that enables us to
give us proposals
for if something is bad or
if something is the floor.
And you can probably
see how this
could be extremely
valuable for all kinds
of robotic applications, where
now, the robot can actually
figure out what to do in
relation to these objects,
where we can have
human interaction that
relates to these objects
that are identified.
OK.
So I don't know how
technical you all
are, but I assume some of
you are exposed to machine
learning-- deep learning.
So let me just talk
about this a little bit.
I think there is
a bit of a split
in the community between
using models, using kind
of more engineering
based approaches,
versus deep learning--
everything using data driven
approaches and kind of treat
that as an end to end black box
problem that you want to solve.
So I often find myself a little
bit in a defensive position
for models.
So let me start with that.
I think models are still
very useful, even these days.
They're very compact.
With very few
parameters, you can
explain an awful lot of things.
They generalize, also, well
beyond the training set.
So just to give
an example here, I
would argue that
discovering physics--
the law of physics--
kind of very low
parametric models
have allowed us to do things
that are definitely not found
in any training data
set before that.
And kind of seemingly applied to
the spatial perception problem,
the kind of traditional
models-- geometric models,
probabilistic models--
they have really been the
success story for a very long
time to enable robotics.
But on the other hand, use
of learning-- deep learning--
is absolutely really amazing.
And this is fairly
new how powerful
we see these methods can be.
I would argue that
it can be used
in a very much complementary
way, learning relationships
that are simply too
complex to model.
You need to extract
it from data.
Especially kind of doing things
like semantic understanding--
that's absolutely the way to go,
and we should combine the two
things together.
And this is very much the
same spirit of what we're
doing with the Plastic Tide
is to combine these things
together, to combine
mapping and semantic
understanding together.
But just to show what we can
do using only the kind of more
traditional, but still kind of
modern model based approach,
this is a fully autonomous
drone that we have put together.
I kind of chose the
whole cycle that I've
shown in the very beginning--
everything operating here.
This is a fully autonomous drone
without the need for any GPS
or any other external
kind of sensing.
It has a color and
depth camera, including
inertial sensing here.
And then we have a kind of
Intel Nook computer here.
It's relatively standard,
so this is actually
assembled from quite
standard components without--
it's not a very expensive drone.
Downward looking
camera, as well.
So what we are
doing here is we're
trying to land on
a moving platform,
and so this is deployed in
real-- this is completely
without any human interaction.
It's just a one button
press for the takeoff,
and then someone
has to run around.
That used to be me, normally.
So it flies to that
hovering point,
and then it automatically
detects and tracks the moving
target, and it will
land on it safely.
And the tricky bit is it
doesn't have to just work once.
It has to work under different
environmental conditions,
even on a nice, sunny day.
Wind and so on.
So don't just do it once
for a paper-- you submit it
and you're done.
This has to work
really robustly.
I guess that's the
main challenge here.
But it can be done.
So there's absolutely
no learning involved.
But at the same
time, I guess, we
have to understand the limits.
So let me just
bring up this slide.
I won't go into too
much technical details,
but effectively, the kind
of traditional approach
to simultaneous
localization and mapping--
SLAM-- consists of very
much building these models.
So what we do is we model
out the measurements
as samples from
probability distribution,
and then we're trying to
find the values that best
explain all the measurements.
This is instantiations
of a maximum likelihood
or maximum a posterior
problem, usually.
And we have to take a couple
of engineering decisions.
We have to decide how we
want to represent the robot,
where it is positioned,
what orientation, and so on,
as well as how we represent
the environment-- the map.
Then we have to model
these distributions,
and then here is the
most engineering, really.
We have to choose a lot
of approximations-- ways
of how to solve
this optimization
problem, for instance,
or a filtering problem.
We have to find, also,
some way to initialize
to bootstrap to get started.
And so that's a traditional
way of doing it.
And now we can
bring in learning.
We can bring in
learning, for instance,
to have the semantic map
layer that I mentioned before.
We also can find
representations that
are sort of aware of
the semantics behind it.
It's very wasteful
to try and represent
a map with just millions
and billions of points.
For instance, how
we can try and find
more compact representations.
We can also learn geometry.
So this is another
very interesting field
at the moment where
deep learning can
be leveraged to actually
understand geometric priors
from just looking at an image.
OK.
So just to give you
an example-- so this
is how we would, for instance,
represent the state of a drone.
So this could be a drone as
it is being flown autonomously
to inspect a beach.
At the moment, in
the Plastic Tide,
we were still using
manually controlled drones,
I should say, but this is now
our fully autonomous drone
that we have at the lab.
So we would usually have
a kind of a combination
of this is position and
orientation of the drone--
a combination of
kind of physical
states that we
need to control it.
Also, the velocity here.
But then things like
online calibration
to calibrate the
cameras, with respect
to each other, even
in the real time
operation, as well as some
sensor intrinsic kind of biases
that we need to estimate.
So you can see this kind
of just shows a little bit
this kind of first choice
that we have to make,
in terms of how to
represent the state.
And then here's
the second choice,
and I think this is
also super critical,
and it really depends on the
application you want to target.
On how to represent
the environment,
traditionally, things like
point clouds were used.
We also see fully--
[CHIME SOUND]
Oh, sorry about that.
We see fully
volumetric approaches.
We see meshes.
They all have their
advantages and disadvantages,
so I'll show a couple
of examples about that.
And so in the most
traditional kind of way,
we might just
represent the world
as a couple of sparse 3D points.
So when you now try to do the
mapping process or the SLAM--
the simultaneous localization
and mapping process--
you have to first identify
corresponding points
from one image to the next,
or just between images.
So this is an example of
how this is being done.
You have to detect
points and then
you have to find a
way to match them
with some kind of
local descriptors.
So this is the vision side.
So the vision side of
things gives you some kind
of spatial information, right?
Gives you, ultimately,
information
about how the camera
has moved as a relative
pose-- how the
camera has changed.
And now, we can
also combine that
with complementary sensing,
like inertial ones.
And this really is the
backbone of any kind
of autonomous drone
operation these days,
is to combine these two.
So here is just some
work that does that.
You can see here
how the camera is--
how images are matched.
How key points are matched
with respect to life-- image
here with respect to a
key-frame in the past.
And on the right hand side, you
can see how now, this estimator
estimates where these 3D points
or 3D points are in the world,
as well as where the drone is
located as it's flying around,
including the orientation.
And again, this has
to run in real time.
It has to run in real time
on relatively constrained
platforms.
We're still talking
about a kind of i7 here,
so it's not as bad
as it could be.
And then it has to be accurate.
It has to be robust, also, when
you have aggressive motion--
motion blur, potentially.
And low lighting, difficult
lighting conditions here.
OK.
And then at some point,
the drone is coming back,
and you will see that it's
pretty much coming back
to the same position in the end.
I'll skip the rest here.
But this is the kind of
missions that we can do now.
If we sort of know
where it is safe to fly,
we can completely autonomously
create the mission.
We can send the
drone to way-points
and do something
complete autonomously.
OK.
So that was the
kind of first layer
of simultaneous
localization and mapping.
Clearly, we would like
to go beyond that.
We would like to enable
avoidance of collision.
We would like to deploy
these robots in environments
that are not as trivial.
And so we've also created
some dense mapping approaches
where now, this is actually
using depth cameras.
So we have-- as an input, you'll
see that in a second here,
the RGB image-- the live
feed, as well as the depth
images from the camera, and the
camera is being moved around.
And we kind of stitched together
these little snapshots of a map
by simultaneously
finding out in a kind
of alternate fashion here--
first, we tried to find out
how the camera is moved,
and then you put
the new information
into a very dense map.
And we can actually
also correct drift.
This is something that
will always happen.
Once you move it
around in a loop or so,
you come back to a place
that you've seen before.
You will have some
accumulated drift.
You will start to remap
the same instance again,
and here we can detect that
and we can make corrections.
We can actually deform
the map and have
a consistent map over a long
time that we put together.
OK.
So this is the kind
of technologies
that you can use now to
have a second level that
enables collision avoidance
and path planning.
But let's now get to
semantics because this is also
what we are leveraging
into Plastic Tide.
So once you have a method
that lets you create a map
and potentially
simultaneously tracking
the motion of a camera,
now we can augment the map
using some kind of semantics.
So here, we are using exactly
this kind of process I've just
shown on the slide before.
OK.
So here, it runs in parallel.
And then we run deep learning
enabled semantic segmentation
on top of that.
So the principle will
just show in a second.
So we use the live feed
from the camera RGB
image plus depth image.
We do a reconstruction--
a dense map.
And now we use, in
parallel, the same inputs,
feed them through a
convolutional neural network.
And the convolutional
neural network
was previously trained
with lots of data.
That's the key here.
We need lots of
data to train it,
such that it can then
make these predictions.
It can interpret the data and
it can find out, OK, well, this
is floor.
This is sofa.
And it will give us these
maps as probability maps,
essentially, where
we can interpret
the output after the
training as probability maps.
And we can fuse
this information.
We can accumulate this
information into the 3D world,
so we get a semantic
map in the end.
So in some sense,
this is already
kind of how I see how the
Plastic Tide, version 2.0 could
work, where we have a very
accurate, very dense 3D
representation of the world.
And we have annotations
about what these things are.
So here, this is an
indoor environment.
It was trained with things like
floor and windows and chairs,
but you could imagine
that these could
be-- with the right
training data sets,
these could be different
kinds of plastic pieces
that we can very
accurately now localize
and map in the 3D world.
I'll somewhat keep
that data here.
The interesting bit
is that actually,
accumulating this semantic
information in the 3D world
helps you--
getting more accurate in
your semantic segmentation
when you just project
it to the 2D image.
So it was an
interesting finding.
OK.
So now, linking that
to the Plastic Tide.
It's a very much
similar process, right?
So we accumulate.
We now have to get
very specific data.
That's the trick about
machine learning.
We need to find the environment
in which we want to deploy
the system, ultimately.
We need to create
training data there.
And so this is--
thanks to Pete and Ellie here
that went around and collected
a lot of drone footage.
Again, this is
manually controlled,
but it really doesn't matter.
It's just a matter of
creating a lot of--
[CHIME SOUND]
I switched this off.
Somehow, it doesn't
seem to care.
Sorry.
So you have to create
a lot of imagery,
and then it has to be tagged.
We have some--
Pete has all the statistics
about how many tags we have.
We had to split up the
original high resolution drone
images into tiles, then they
are presented to the taggers.
We got a lot of ground
truth annotations,
and we train our network.
In our case, it is
the YOLO, version 2,
simultaneous bounding box
detection and classification
algorithm that we use.
So we didn't--
I'm not a deep learning expert.
We didn't kind of try and
change the architecture
of this network, but the way you
can think about it, for those
who are not experts
in machine learning,
is that you have this network
that effectively consists
of a lot a lot of parameters--
probably millions of parameters
that are then being learned.
It fits the data, right?
That when you input the data
here, that will be an image,
such that you actually
get the kind of outputs
that you give in training.
So you're trying-- you're giving
it a lot of examples like this,
and ultimately, it will be
able to autonomously detect
these kind of plastic pieces.
So here, this is a level of just
bounding boxes that we get out.
The example before
showed segmentation.
So that's where we
want to ultimately get
to, as well, but I think this
is a very important starting
point-- to just
have bounding boxes
and kind of a rough idea of
where these pieces of plastics
are actually located.
So here's a couple of examples
of how that actually then works
in practice.
This is very much ongoing work.
We're trying to improve
that at the moment.
And so this is just
at the level of when
imaging, what kind of plastics
can we detect in the image?
You can see here that's now--
just to emphasize
that one more time,
this is now not training data.
That is what the
network has learned.
So this is completely automatic.
You give it an image--
it will tell you
where all the plastic
pieces-- and it finds
some really quite surprisingly
small things, as well.
But it also makes
mistakes, right?
So here, for instance, you
see it has kind of double
detected the same thing.
Here, as well.
I think here, it's
missed something.
Although I can barely
see that on the screen,
so it does miss certain things.
They're also actually
difficult to see for people.
So I'm confident that
with enough data,
we can train an algorithm
that will be at least as
good as people are.
So that should be
really the goal, right?
That we can automate this
process of then ultimately
mapping these pieces, right?
So this is the idea--
that we can now
put the kind of
mapping infrastructure
that I've shown before--
we can put that together.
Assuming we have, now, the
very precise localizations
for where these
images were taken,
we can triangulate them
into the real world,
combine that with
GPS knowledge, and we
will have a very accurate map of
where there are plastic pieces.
At the moment, still just
kind of bounding boxes
kind of in 3D in the end, but
the goal is to go beyond that.
I will skip this for a
second and I will just
mention this, as well.
So just talking about training
data in the case of the Plastic
Tide, we made a lot of
effort to actually get
this training data--
real training data out there.
Indoors, in the lab,
we work with, also,
synthetic training data.
So this is a sort
of way around it.
For these machine
learning algorithms,
you need a lot of training data.
You need hundreds of thousands
and millions, maybe, of images.
But we can get the way
to some degree, at least,
with simulating, actually.
So we have built
some simulators,
simulating indoor
environments that
gave us perfect ground truth.
But of course, there's always
a question about how realistic
these images are.
So a bit of a messy
room here, actually.
You would hope to not
necessarily see that, really.
But we want to
train the algorithms
to be able to deal with
any kind of situation.
OK, so this is kind
of open training data
sets that we have.
We are also moving
somewhat beyond that
with very realistic-- trying
to get more realistic training
data sets with having very
professionally designed
interior design
kind of elements,
and then we can render
scenes like that.
But you can imagine that
replicating this process
is probably quite difficult
for a specific setting
like outdoors and beaches,
where there's just
very little understanding,
also, about what's going on.
So here, we can leverage
designs that people
have made in the past.
And maybe a bit, also,
more interestingly
in the robotic
context, if you want
to have a ground robot,
what we can do now
is we can render the scene from
a quite unusual perspective.
And I think this is, again,
kind of in the same spirit,
as I mentioned before--
you have to make this specific
for the application, right?
You have to have
the right training
data for the right application.
So if you have a ground
robot, you probably
want some kind of ground
robot type footage.
If you want a drone that
finds plastic pieces,
you need training data from
plastic pieces on the beach.
OK.
So I think I'll close on that
note and hand over back to Pete
to explain, a little bit,
the next steps, I believe,
of the Plastic Tide.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER KOHLER: Thanks, Stefan.
So that's a really
fascinating, in-depth look
at sort of what's happening
behind the scenes.
So when we're talking
about machine learning
and how we apply
it, that's the sort
of output and the
type of things we're
aiming for for
that algorithm 2.0.
So for our sort of
production algorithm that we
want to get to, which
we're working on now,
is sort of being
able to localize,
identify where the
plastic item is
in its location, what size
it is, what kind it is,
eventually.
Also, the sort of volume--
using the SLAM techniques
that Stefan was talking about,
as well as having autonomous
platform to scale.
So you're not just--
we'll talk about
it in a second--
scaling.
But as long as that's
within the sort
of legal and safe framework.
So I think there's a bit of
human interaction at the start
to ensure that those
platforms operate
within safe environments,
especially given
congested airspace like is
around Southeast England.
So what does it all mean?
So great.
We've got the scanning, we've
got the data, but how will
this have an impact?
What I saw at the very beginning
and my journey to that broader
understanding of the problem
of where plastics are,
and then eventually, how
we can help prevent--
how revealing-- how
all this technology
that reveals the
extent of the problem
can help prevent the
problem in the first place,
as well as help clean it up.
And so the first thing is
the localization and trend
analysis.
So this data is actually
data that we manually
collected, but eventually,
through the algorithm outputs,
we'll be able to
sort of heat map--
analyze concentrations
of plastics,
and then sort of pull from
that data about the types
of plastics all
sorts of analysis,
again, depending
on the requirement.
And this data is the thing
that's missing at the moment.
This sort of scale,
because it only
happens in very localized ways.
It's very hard for the person
to get the exact same volunteers
to go to the exact
same beach that they
were before and recorded
it in the exact same way,
whereas the algorithm, although
it's not going to be perfect--
we don't think we can
get it up to 100% at all,
but at least if
there are errors,
they're more consistent,
which allows scientists
to understand that background.
And that sort of thing
can inform things
like legal monitoring
enforcement.
So there's all
sorts of conventions
now from the UNCLOS--
the United Nations
Law of the Sea, which
is all about monitoring impact.
So if there's
leakage into the sea,
member states have an obligation
to then monitor how that
is impacting the environment.
That has then been
transposed to EU regulations
for the European Environmental
Strategic Marine Framework
Directive, and they've got
a policy cycle here, again,
where they need to monitor.
So guess is good
environmental standard.
Lots of things involved
in that, but one of them
is, again, marine
litter on beaches.
So when you go to a beach and
you see lots of marine litter,
legally now, that
shouldn't be there.
All states should be monitoring
that and putting plans in
to prevent it.
So this is part of the
strategy, and that all
comes under the
Honolulu strategy, which
was a big effort to get not just
policy people in governments,
but also companies
involved in that
design and the appreciation
of how do plastics break down?
What are the most ones?
How can we identify which
are the most offending ones?
And this is a lot of sort
of Dr. Arturo's work here-
Dr. Castillo's work.
To quantify risk to wildlife.
So as you saw, some of
these pictures-- this is one
that someone sent in.
The seagull-- he caught a
Seagull eating a bit of plastic
on the beach right
in front of him
as he was doing a drone scan.
So if we understand the sizes
of plastics and where they
concentrate-- and there are
some [INAUDIBLE] calls--
some research calls
now about this
and using the
localization and SLAM--
the semantic segmentation--
we can understand the sizes
and types, and
that will allow us
to sort of map that with, say,
feeding patterns of albatross.
So we can then identify
those marine environments
that are most vulnerable
to plastic contamination.
But also, to quantify
the risk to humans.
So this is in Tonga.
This is Nuku'alofa.
This is not far from where
I was in the South Pacific,
and it helps us understand
the risks to humans.
So whilst we don't
yet understand
the transfer of toxins and
that subject for intense study
at the moment,
the UN is advising
it a precautionary principle.
So rather than waiting for
the stuff to hit the fan,
we do something about it now.
And so it's really important,
understanding with something
like--
I think it's half the world's
population lives within 100
kilometers of the coast.
So there's an important
interaction going on here.
It allows us to quantify that.
Economic damage to shipping.
Here's a ship's propeller
tangled with a netting.
And that ship is then disabled.
That ship is then vulnerable.
If it was in a
storm, it would be
vulnerable to capsizing that.
To the tourist industry.
I've got friends
who've gone to Phuket,
and they now see plastic
all over the place.
And that impacts-- no one
wants to go to a beach
and sit in, basically,
a rubbish heap.
So there's a lot of interest
in there, as well as below
is the sort of economic
environment affecting
harbors and ships.
So there's lots of potential
applications in that area.
And then that can
lead to, obviously,
coordinating the removal.
So this is the group of us here.
This is the final beach
clean in Dovercourt in Essex.
And help more effective-- from
local organizations, volunteer
groups, all the way up to
sort of governmental level
to help pinpoint the best
areas-- you know, the most
effective areas to clean.
Because if we know
how much of the litter
is coming in from the
sea, how much of it
is coming from the land,
where it accumulates--
it will help us
tackle that aspect.
It could help us identify what
types of plastic, which then
leads onto the next sort of
element, which is informing
campaigns and effectiveness.
So if you say, all
right, well we're
going to ban all
drink bottles or we're
going to instigate a
deposit return scheme.
Well, how do you measure
how successful that is?
Without that data, it's
difficult to lobby.
There's one less, as well.
There's Sky now is passing
single use plastic.
Passing plastics.
There's some great
campaigns out there,
but we need to understand
what sort of impact they're
having on the environment
to ensure that they're
the best they can be to
really help get to that end
goal of a cleaner ocean.
Some of the impacts,
and then not long now.
It's nearly finished.
We've done over 33 beaches
with over 100 volunteers.
A ton of litter.
14,000 drone images.
I think we've probably got--
because each drone image is
divided into about 25 tiles
because of the resolution,
and each tile is then
uploaded to Zooniverse.
So I think we're more in the
region of half a million images
that we've gone through.
We've had over
10,000 volunteers.
We're nearly at 4
million tags now.
Last week, for British Science
Week a couple weeks ago,
we got 1 and 1/2 million in
five days, which was incredible.
Tens to hundreds of schools--
we know lots of schools got in.
The demand peaked during school
hours form 10:00 to 3:00 PM.
We were getting something
like 1,000 tags a minute
or something like that.
It was incredible.
And it's national, and
eventually international.
And then tomorrow-- so
this is the phase two.
This is sort of 2.0, which
we were talking about.
The production algorithm--
a global database.
All of that imagery--
that data gets uploaded
to a map online,
where you can then view,
visualize, and query the data.
Eventually, autonomous
drone platforms--
open-source.
So we want to release as
much as we can open source--
as open source licenses.
Extending it to the sea floor,
sea surface, and rivers.
So you remember that
diagram at the beginning
where we looked
at all the fluxes.
So retraining the dataset.
And we're working on prototypes
now for the sea floor,
for example, so keep
an eye out for that.
Moving to multi-spectral
and hyper-spectral imagery.
Then satellite sensing--
potentially even
gamifying the citizen
science element.
So that's a very dry
interaction at the moment.
It's only great on computers.
It's not great on
mobiles because it's
a volunteer platform.
They do it free of charge.
That's Zooniverse.
It's part of Oxford.
And sort of drone
survey standards--
it's setting up an international
standard for drone surveying,
which we are--
we've set up a marina to
drone net to support that.
We've got people
from around the world
on that, which we're
launching on Sunday,
which is World Earth Day.
And then just a little
about the timelines.
Rough approximation of
the sort of timelines
in which we're looking at that.
How to get involved.
I'll send some links
around to Florian.
Numero uno is get tagging.
Also, I think we're now
registered with Google Giving,
I think it is.
Yeah, so if you want to
give some of your time
or some of your
efforts, you can tag.
We'll be setting up
beach cleans, as well.
So go to our website,
www.ThePlasticTide.com,
and you'll see all the latest
things that we're doing.
I've got a talk next
Tuesday at a conference.
Yeah, I think that's it.
So I think any questions,
and thank everyone.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Oh.
So did you say--
I thought a couple of slides
back that we can actually
go down and take our own drone
images, which we can then
get people to tag?
PETER KOHLER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PETER KOHLER: Potentially, yes.
We do that.
Ellie and I set up a sort of
standard where you can donate.
We have a structure where you
basically-- it gives the images
and then we upload them.
But eventually, once we've got
enough of that training data,
we'll be moving away from that.
But there are areas
where we can explore it
for further citizen science.
So we know that when people
have had to look closely
on the tagging side, you then
start to see a lot more of it
outside.
And that starts to change
your behavior, and so we've--
like I said, we've
got a researcher
who's looking into that now.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
And for the image
quality, do they
need to be of a specific image
quality-- the drone images?
PETER KOHLER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering how
flexible your platform would
be for other forms of
environmental aerial survey.
So I know that, for
instance, people
are looking at the
spread of sudden--
tree diseases, say,
from canopy surveys.
And I wondered
whether-- it seems
like a lot of the
platform, you would
have already built for this.
And maybe it's just the final
bit of visual machine learning
that would be required to
be changed to do things
like handling
multi-spectral images
and looking at tree health.
STEFAN LEUTENEGGER:
Yeah, I guess
this is somewhat a question
for both of us, right?
But I mean, from
the machine learning
perspective and the
robotics perspective,
you're absolutely right.
It doesn't really change
the principles behind it.
But at the same time, you
still need the training data
that is specific to
that application.
And I think that's-- yeah,
that's when the Plastic Tide
kind of set up the need to come
in for a different application.
But yeah, in principle,
it would be ready, right?
Also, Zooniverse or other
platforms that enable tagging--
they are out there.
PETER KOHLER: There are or there
were canopy tagging platforms
on that.
And we're sort of
talking about--
when we're doing the seafloor
monitoring and potentially,
on the beaches, as
well as perhaps looking
at marine life in
keystone species.
But again, it's very
difficult because you've
got to think about the
tagger on the other side
and their level of expertise.
So it's quite a balancing act.
You don't want to overload them.
Otherwise, you're just not
going to get the volume
that you need.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for an
interesting presentation.
I wonder if the technology
enables us today
to scan the ocean--
all the seas and to get the
exact picture, because you
mentioned that 99%--
it goes and sinks to the
oceans or the water, right?
And that 1% is--
it's kind of rough
calculation, maybe.
But if the technology
enables us today,
and another is how we
influence all the-- once
we get all the data, how we
influence to that, because you
mentioned the policy.
How we influence policy
makers or the consumers
in the future to kind of
restrain from the plastic use
or to ban the plastic
for the future
because I know they
are the [INAUDIBLE]
I think that France
introduced the policy where
they ban the plastics,
and some of the countries
are in the queue, as well.
STEFAN LEUTENEGGER:
Just today, actually, I
think there was news
that for the UK,
plastic straws will be banned.
Oh.
OK.
PETER KOHLER: Got rid of
plastic straws, apparently.
There you go.
STEFAN LEUTENEGGER:
They are banned.
So definitely, I think
politics are waking up.
There still needs a lot more
waking up, and then actual
action to follow.
But yeah.
I hope we can feed some of that.
Data but that's
probably more of your--
PETER KOHLER: Yeah,
I think-- well,
we've got an expert in
the house right here.
So I think if we can pass
the microphone to Arturo.
So Dr. Arturo is an Imperial--
ARTURO CASTILLO: So we know
what the policy making cycle is,
and it all starts with, also,
sentiment monitoring of people.
So politicians and
policymakers don't
move unless they
know that there is
a demand and the need
for all these policies
to actually take place.
And the way the
Plastic Tide can do
that is by informing
what are the trends, what
is the frequency and the hot
spots of all this damage that
is accumulating, and
raising the awareness.
So this is very important
that this has two elements.
One is the monitoring, but the
other one is the education.
And the moment that
people are educated,
then both the demand and the
welcoming of the policies
will be much easier.
MODERATOR: We are
running out of time,
so if you close here--
again, thank you very much.
PETER KOHLER: Thank you.
STEFAN LEUTENEGGER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]